[Music]
hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Sony have announced the seven games
we'll be getting as part of PlayStation
Plus for the month of August 2017 three
for the ps4 two for the PlayStation 3
and two for the Vita as well with one of
those being playable on the ps4 this
monks offerings include an open-world
extravaganza a pirate assassination
title a cooperative digging game and the
masterpiece about Gary I'll explain that
one soon all the following games will be
available on Tuesday the 1st of August
as always let's start with the games on
the ps4 and what a game to start with
Just Cause 3 this is an action-adventure
title where the open world is your
playground set six years after Just
Cause 2 we join Rico Rodriguez as he
returns home to take down a brutal
dictator the destruction mechanics and
the ways to traverse the world are
simply brilliant and so worth your time
the wingsuit is so much fun the vehicles
are varied and the weapons are perfect
for any self-respecting homicidal maniac
this is on victims solid eight out of
ten reviews from most outlets but
Metacritic only has this one at 73%
surprisingly this is definitely one for
your collection if you don't have it
already
next up is Assassin's Creed freedom cry
this one is the DLC for Assassin's Creed
4 Black Flag which was also a standalone
product so don't worry if you don't have
black plug in your library already this
is a two year story from 1735 to 1737
and focuses around assassin Adewale I am
so sorry have said that wrong it's all
about his struggles to take down French
slavers it has all the hallmarks of a
great Assassin's Creed title and
although it to cut down experience in
time and length it's still a great way
to prepare yourself for origins coming
later in the year
IGN gave this one 7 out of 10 so
definitely worth a look if I do say so
myself
it has pirates in it so don't fly for
too long you may get booked a quick
reminder that that's you is still
available as part of Pearce Plus so if
you missed it last month you can still
grab it now over to the ps3 and the
unique game super mother lode this is a
wonderful player couch co-op digging
adventure
you player the pilot sent to gather
resources under the surface of Mars but
as you descend you learn more about the
secrets of Mars and some strange
occurrences pop up during each
playthrough not to oversell it but there
are some horror elements to this one and
your puzzle and problem solving skills
will definitely be tested super mother
lode achieved a bucket load of six out
of ten review scores with Destructoid
giving it a whopping 8 out of 10 even
the PlayStation Blog gave it the editors
choice back in 2013
next on the ps3 is sake for a PSN game
from 2007 did you ever play snake on an
old Nokia mobile phone well think of it
like a 3d reimagining with a disco vibe
running through it to be more specific
it's actually based on a game from the
1970s and which you are tasked with
throwing a ball into a hole it comes
into its own when played with friends as
avoiding each other's tails and the
weapons that drop can be quite intense
it's no triple a game but could be worth
a playthrough if you're in the mood
anybody grabbing this one I'd love to
know over to the Vita and down well
which is also available on the ps4 you
are tasked with jumping down a well to
search for treasure with a trusty pair
of gun bootstrap the offbeat it's a
mobile game winning many awards for its
iPhone version so the developers I've
tried to bring it over to the Vita I
don't know this one very well so I'm in
need of an opinion here should we play
it or should we avoid this one finally
level 22 the world's first stealth game
set in the world of work you play as
Gary Gary no no that was this one he'd
like the work after a hard night of
drinking and if he's late one more time
he loses his job your job is to get him
to his desk without anyone seeing him
hide in cupboards crawl through air
vents on stealth your way up to level 20
- I won't lie here I am so looking
forward to playing this one what do you
think do you have a Vita if so is it
stuck in a drawer getting dusty so there
we go that's August 2017 for PS plus
it's a damn good month if I do say so
myself I'll be grabbing Just Cause 3
freedom cry and level 22 when they
become available on Tuesday August the
1st
what about you what are you grabbing and
what do you think to the quality
increase in PS Plus over the last three
months if this is useful alike would be
really
appreciated and if you aren't happy with
the games being offered go on a run in
the comments below I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade as always it's been
a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
you